This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Some months ago, I brought seven key insights from the first decade of Hidden Brain to live stage performances in San Francisco and Seattle. The evenings were electric. Electric. We got so much positive feedback from those two sold out shows that we've decided to launch a tour to more than a dozen cities in the coming months. I'll be coming to Portland, Denver, Minneapolis, Chicago, Austin, Dallas, Boston, Toronto, Clearwater, Fort Lauderdale, Phoenix, Baltimore, Washington, D.C., and Los Angeles. To snap up your tickets, please go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几个月前，我将《隐藏的大脑》开播前十年的七个核心洞察搬到了旧金山和西雅图的现场表演舞台上。那几个夜晚的气氛简直嗨翻了。嗨翻了。这两场票售一空的演出收到了如此多的积极反馈，以至于我们决定在接下来的几个月里启动一个涵盖十几个城市的巡演。我将去往波特兰、丹佛、明尼阿波利斯、芝加哥、奥斯汀、达拉斯、波士顿、多伦多、克利尔沃特、劳德代尔堡、菲尼克斯、巴尔的摩、华盛顿特区和洛杉矶。想要抢购门票，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。
You can also sign up to say hello and get a photo with me. In some places, you can sign up for an intimate chat with me and a handful of other fans. I'd love to see you there. Again, go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. Okay, on to today's show. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Almost exactly a century ago, a British ship, the Endurance, became trapped in Antarctic sea ice. Aboard were 28 men, led by the explorer, Ernest Shackleton. On October 27th, 1915, the pressure of the ice crushed the keel of the Endurance. Freezing water rushed in.
你也可以报名与我打招呼并合影留念。在某些地方，你还可以报名参加与我和少数其他粉丝的亲密交流。我很期待在那里见到你。再次重申，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。好的，进入今天的节目。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。就在将近整整一个世纪前，一艘英国船只“坚忍号”被困在了南极海冰中。船上有 28 名船员，由探险家欧内斯特·沙克尔顿率领。1915 年 10 月 27 日，冰层的压力压碎了“坚忍号”的龙骨。冰冷的湖水汹涌而入。
The sailors dragged lifeboats and supplies from the ship onto the ice. Carrying the lifeboats, they started hiking toward open water. After a week with little progress, Ernest Shackleton realized they would be better off camping on an ice flow and waiting for it to drift toward open water. What followed was an extraordinary story of knowledge and resourcefulness. The explorers managed to get their lifeboats into the water and row to dry land, a place called Elephant Island. But the desolate island offered little by way of resources and no hope of rescue.
水手们把救生艇和补给品从船上拖到冰面上。他们带着救生艇，开始向开阔水域徒步前进。经过一周进展甚微的跋涉后，欧内斯特·沙克尔顿意识到，他们最好是在冰面上扎营，等待冰面漂向开阔水域。接下来发生的是一个关于知识和应变能力的非凡故事。探险家们设法将救生艇放入水中，划行到陆地上，一个被称为象岛的地方。但这个荒凉的岛屿几乎无法提供什么资源，也没有获救的希望。
So Ernest Shackleton and a smaller group took one of the lifeboats and set out for a whaling station. It was 800 miles away. Across seas were towering waves and deadly storms. The explorers had only basic navigation equipment. Somehow, using the stars to guide them, they made it to the island of South Georgia. But storms had blown them to the wrong side of the island as the whaling station.
因此，欧内斯特·沙克尔顿和一小队人乘一艘救生艇出发去寻找一个捕鲸站。那是 800 英里之外。穿越波涛汹涌、巨浪滔天且风暴致命的海域。探险家们只有最基础的导航设备。不知怎的，他们依靠星星指引方向，成功抵达了南乔治亚岛。但风暴把他们吹到了距离捕鲸站错误的一侧岛屿。
They now had to hike across the island, across frozen mountains and icy glaciers to reach help. Ernest Shackleton eventually commanded a ship back to Elephant Island to rescue the remainder of his crew. He saved every last man. This is the kind of story that is popular in novels and movies. The explorers came up with creative solutions to problems and displayed a deep understanding of the challenges before them. They kept their heads and saved themselves. Stories like this obscure how much we understand about our own worlds. When we face obstacles, even simple problems like a puncture a tire, a malfunctioning phone, or an odd pain in our stomachs, are
他们现在必须徒步穿过这座岛屿，翻越南极冰冻的山脉和冰川才能寻求救援。欧内斯特·沙克尔顿最终指挥一艘船返回象岛去救援其余的船员。他拯救了最后一个人。这就是那种在小说和电影中很受欢迎的故事。探险家们对问题想出了创意的解决方法，并表现出对他们所面临挑战的深刻理解。他们保持冷静，自救成功。像这样的故事掩盖了我们对自身世界了解的程度。当我们面对障碍时，甚至是像轮胎漏气、手机故障或胃部隐痛这样简单的问题，
we any good at figuring out what to do? Closing the gap between what we know and what we think we know. This week on Hidden Brain. Human beings are, as far as we know, the most intelligent creatures ever produced by evolution. Our brains are unimaginably complex and capable of extraordinary feats of invention and creativity. And yet, these amazing minds also come with certain limits. At the University of Colorado Boulder, Philip Fernbach is a cognitive scientist. He has spent many years studying a rather humbling question. How much do we actually know about the world in which
我们是否擅长弄清楚该做什么？缩小我们所知道的与我们认为自己知道的之间的差距。本周《隐藏的大脑》。据我们所知，人类是有史以来进化产生的最聪明的生物。我们的大脑极其复杂，能够做出非凡的发明和创造。然而，这些惊人的大脑也伴随着一定的局限性。在科罗拉多大学博尔德分校，菲利普·费恩巴赫是一位认知科学家。他花了很多年时间研究一个相当引人深思的问题。我们对我们生活的世界实际上了解多少？
we live? Phil Fernbach, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's great to be with you, Shankar. Thank you. Phil, in 1946, eight men gathered in a nuclear lab in Los Alamos, New Mexico. They were there to watch a distinguished researcher perform a maneuver known as tickling the dragon's tail. Who were these people, Phil? What was going on? This was one of the most fascinating periods in American history. It was the development of the nuclear bomb at Los Alamos in New Mexico.
菲尔·费恩巴赫，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴能和你在一起，尚卡尔。谢谢你。菲尔，1946 年，八名男子聚集在新墨西哥州洛斯阿拉莫斯的一个核实验室里。他们到那里去观看一位杰出的研究人员表演一种被称为“逗弄恶龙尾巴”的操作。这些人是谁，菲尔？当时发生了什么？这是美国历史上最迷人的时期之一。那是新墨西哥州洛斯阿拉莫斯原子弹的研发时期。
And these were very eminent physicists who were testing the reaction of the fissile material in the bomb, the plutonium. And this particular experiment, which the physicist Richard Feynman, as you said, called tickling the Dragon's Dale. It was a very delicate experiment that involved taking two hemispheres of beryllium that were surrounding the plutonium
这些是非常杰出的物理学家，他们正在测试炸弹中可裂变材料（即钚）的反应。正如你所说，物理学家理查德·费曼称这个特定的实验为“逗弄恶龙的尾巴”。这是一个非常微妙的实验，涉及将环绕在钚核心周围的两个铍半球
core and moving them closer and closer together to test the reactivity of the plutonium. So the plutonium is radioactive and gives off neutrons. Those neutrons rebound off of the beryllium and create the reaction. As the hemispheres get closer together, you get more of that reaction. What's so delicate and dangerous about this experiment is that if the hemispheres get too close together,
拿得越来越近，以测试钚的反应活性。所以钚是放射性的并会释放中子。这些中子从铍上反弹并产生反应。当半球靠得更近时，你就会得到更多这种反应。这个实验如此微妙和危险的原因是，如果半球靠得太近，
it can create a chain reaction that releases a burst of radioactivity that can be very dangerous. releases a burst of radioactivity that can be very dangerous. So the lead scientist who was running this experiment, who was tickling the dragon's tail, if you will, was named Lewis Slotin, and he was a very experienced physicist, was he not? He was. He was one of the developers of the bomb and was an extremely eminent and
它会产生连锁反应，释放出一股非常危险的放射性辐射。释放出一股非常危险的放射性辐射。所以进行这个实验、也就是“逗弄恶龙尾巴”的首席科学家名叫刘易斯·斯洛廷，他是一位经验非常丰富的物理学家，对吗？是的。他是炸弹的开发者之一，是一位极其杰出且经验丰富的物理学家。
experienced physicist. He was the most important member of this experimental team because he was the one who was actually engaged in the process of bringing those hemispheres of beryllium closer together. How was he doing it? What was he doing? Well, this is the crazy part of the story. He was actually using a common flathead screwdriver to keep the two sections of beryllium apart. Unfortunately, at the critical moment,
他是这个实验团队中最重要的人物，因为他是那个实际参与将那些铍半球拉近过程的人。他是怎么做到的？他在做什么？嗯，这是故事中最疯狂的部分。他实际上是用一把普通的平头螺丝刀来保持两个部分的铍分开。不幸的是，在关键时刻，
the screwdriver slipped. The two hemispheres of beryllium crashed together and they released this intense burst of radioactive radiation. Slotin who was right next to the apparatus took the worst of it and he actually died in the infirmary eight days later of radiation poisoning. The rest of the physicists in the room, all eminent scientists, all survived the initial burst. Some of them unfortunately died before their time potentially due to the radiation dose that they received. Was there a way of conducting this experiment more safely? There certainly was.
螺丝刀滑落了。两个铍半球撞在一起，释放出强烈的放射性辐射。紧挨着仪器的斯洛廷承受了最严重的辐射，八天后他确实在医务室因辐射中毒去世了。房间里的其他物理学家，全都是杰出的科学家，都在最初的辐射爆发中幸存了下来。不幸的是，他们中的一些人英年早逝，这可能与他们受到的辐射剂量有关。有没有更安全地进行这个实验的方法？当然有。
For instance, an obvious way to do it would have been to suspend one of the hemispheres of beryllium and then the other hemisphere could be raised from the bottom. In that case, if anything slipped or there was any problem, gravity would have just pulled the two hemispheres apart. And that would have been much less of a dangerous way to conduct the experiment. Why do you think Lewis Slotin didn't do it that way, Phil? I think, um, Slocum, like any other person, um, by virtue of his experience, did not foresee this potential problem. He became overconfident in his ability to conduct this experiment because he had done
例如，一个显而易见的方法是将一个铍半球悬挂起来，然后从底部向上提升另一个半球。那样的话，如果有什么东西滑落或出现任何问题，重力就会直接把两个半球拉开。进行这个实验的方式就会危险得多。菲尔，你认为为什么刘易斯·斯洛廷不那样做呢？我想，嗯，斯洛姆和任何人一样，由于他的经验，没有预见到这个潜在的问题。他对进行这个实验的能力变得过于自信，因为他以前做过很多次，在这个领域拥有丰富的经验。
it so many times before and he had so much experience in this domain. I want to ask you about another incident that took place many years later. In 2009, Air France flight 447 crashed into the ocean killing more than 200 passengers on board. When the black box of the plane was recovered it appeared that the aircraft had stalled. Can you first explain what a stall is and what you're supposed to do when the plane stalls and what the pilots of flight 447 actually did? A stall is a very scary thing. So that's when an airplane loses airspeed and literally starts falling out of the sky.
我想问你关于多年前发生的另一起事件。2009 年，法航 447 号航班坠入海洋，机上 200 多名乘客遇难。当飞机的黑匣子被找回时，似乎飞机已经失速。你能先解释一下什么是失速、飞机失速时应该做什么，以及 447 航班的飞行员实际做了什么吗？失速是一件非常可怕的事情。那是当飞机失去空速并开始从天空中直往下掉的时候。
Every pilot, when they learn how to fly an airplane, this is one of the most important things that they train for. So they actually will purposely put the airplane into a stall and then learn how to take it out of the stall. How do you take a plane out of a stall? Well, actually what you need to do is point the nose of the plane down, counter-intuitively.
每个飞行员在学习如何驾驶飞机时，这都是他们训练的最重要的内容之一。所以他们实际上会故意让飞机进入失速状态，然后学习如何使飞机脱离失速。你如何让飞机脱离失速？嗯，实际上你需要做的是反直觉地将机头朝下。
You wanna go up, but you actually have to point the plane down. You have to increase your acceleration. You have to regain airspeed, and then you can actually achieve an altitude correction. When they recovered the black box from this airplane, surprisingly what they found was that this very experienced pilot had done was exactly the opposite of what you're supposed
你想往上飞，但实际上你必须把机头朝下。你必须增加加速度。你必须恢复空速，然后你才能真正实现高度修正。当他们从这架飞机上找到黑匣子时，令人惊讶的是，他们发现这位经验丰富的飞行员所做的事，与你在失速情况下应该做的事完全相反。
to do in a stall situation. He was actually trying to pull the plane up, but without any airspeed, that's just impossible. There's no way that the plane could recover. And so unfortunately, this led to this devastating outcome. I'm wondering whether the Federal Aviation Administration or other safety organizations evaluated why the error had come about. Did they look into that film? Yeah, they did very extensive analyses
他实际上是在试图拉起飞机，但在没有空速的情况下，这是不可能的。飞机根本无法恢复。不幸的是，这导致了这个毁灭性的结果。我想知道美国联邦航空局或其他安全组织是否评估了错误是如何产生的。他们调查过那个吗，菲尔？是的，他们做了非常广泛的分析，
to try to figure out what went wrong. And one of their overall conclusions was that pilots in general have become too reliant on automation and have lost some of their basic flying skills. Modern airplanes, especially modern jetliners, are so technologically sophisticated that a lot of the time the software
试图弄清楚哪里出了问题。他们得出的总体结论之一是，飞行员总体上变得过于依赖自动化，并丧失了一些基本的飞行技能。现代飞机，尤其是现代喷气式客机，在技术上如此复杂，以至于很多时候软件和飞机在做大部分工作。
and the airplane are doing most of the work. The pilot is almost like an observer watching the airplane do the job. The pilot of course has to be there to intervene in unusual situations when something goes wrong. The problem is that those situations are becoming more and more rare because the software is becoming more and more capable. So in cases where an intervention is necessary, the pilot might not be as prepared as they should be because they become too reliant on the automation. I mean, I'm thinking in a much, much smaller scale.
飞行员几乎就像一个观察员，看着飞机完成工作。当出现异常情况出问题时，飞行员当然必须在那里进行干预。问题在于，随着软件变得越来越强大，这些情况正变得越来越罕见。因此，在需要干预的情况下，飞行员可能没有他们应有的那么准备充分，因为他们变得过于依赖自动化。我的意思是，我在一个更小得多的规模上思考这个问题。
I am so reliant on my navigation tools and GPS technology to get me around that on the occasions when my phone dies, I suddenly feel like I can't find my way out of a paper bag these days. I've had the exact same experience. In fact, I've heard stories of people driving into lakes because that's what the GPS tells them to do.
我太依赖我的导航工具和 GPS 技术来带我四处出行了，以至于每当我的手机没电时，这些天我突然觉得自己连一张纸包都走不出去了。我有过完全相同的经历。事实上，我听说过有人把车开进湖里的故事，因为 GPS 就是这么指示他们的。
My own personal experience with this is I use self-driving software all the time when I'm driving now. It works remarkably well. But one thing I've noticed over the last few years is that I've actually become a worse driver. No one wants to admit to themselves that they become a worse driver.
我自己的亲身经历是，我现在开车时一直在使用自动驾驶软件。它运行得非常出色。但我过去几年注意到的一件事是，我实际上变成了一个更糟糕的司机。没有人愿意向自己承认自己变成了一个更糟糕的司机。
But for me, the evidence is kind of incontrovertible at this point because I've gotten into a few fender benders over the last few years, which I've never done before. And so I've asked myself, what is going on here? And I really think it's because I've become so reliant on the car doing the work, that I've lost my situational awareness. And then when something unusual happens
但对我来说，目前的证据可以说是无可辩驳的，因为我在过去几年里遭遇了几次轻微刮擦事故，而这以前从未发生过。所以我问自己，这到底是怎么回事？我真的认为这是因为我太依赖汽车来完成工作，以至于我失去了情境意识。然后，当出现不寻常的事情、
and I need to take over, I'm not ready to do it. Just like a pilot on an automated airline. Both the Los Alamos accident and the Air France crash involved highly experienced people who made seemingly elementary mistakes. Phil's research suggests there are many other instances where less experienced people also make blunders, in part because they assume that other smart people
我需要接管时，我还没有准备好这样做。就像自动化航空公司里的飞行员一样。洛斯阿拉莫斯事故和法航坠机事件都涉及高度经验丰富的人，他们犯了看似小学的错误。菲尔的研究表明，还有许多其他情况，经验较少的人也会犯下大错，部分原因在于他们假设其他聪明的人
know what they're doing. Take, for instance, the 2008 financial crash in the United States. The financial crash in 2008 was in a great part due to a massive decline in the value of these financial products, a certain kind of financial product called a derivative. Derivatives are really complicated financial instruments, and it's really hard to predict exactly how they're gonna behave. Traders like derivatives because they can often generate really good returns. In financial markets, return is always correlated with risk.
知道自己在做什么。以美国 2008 年金融危机为例。2008 年的金融危机在很大程度上是由这些金融产品价值的大幅下跌造成的，这是一种特定类型的金融产品，叫做衍生品。衍生品是真正复杂的金融工具，很难准确预测它们的表现。交易员喜欢衍生品，因为它们通常能产生很好的回报。在金融市场中，回报总是与风险相关的。
So if something has a high return, it's also gonna have a high risk. The problem with derivatives is because they're so complicated, it's often impossible to see the risk, or it's very hard to see high risk. The problem with derivatives is because they're so complicated, it's often impossible to see the risk or it's very hard to see the risk. The risk only emerges in sort of unusual situations. So it's like the product is, you know,
所以如果某种东西有高回报，它也必定有高风险。衍生品的问题在于，因为它们太复杂了，通常不可能看出风险，或者很难看出高风险。衍生品的问题在于，因为它们太复杂了，通常不可能看出风险或很难看出风险。风险只在某种不寻常的情况下才会显现。所以这就像这个产品，你知道，
it seems to be behaving just very safely, but then something changes and all of a sudden, instead of losing 10% of its value, it loses 90% of its value or something like that. Now, what ended up happening in the financial crisis was that these derivative products were ending up in places where they didn't belong, in places that should not have been taking on
它似乎表现得非常安全，但随后情况发生了变化，突然之间，它没有损失 10% 的价值，而是损失了 90% 的价值或类似的情况。现在，金融危机中最终发生的事情是，这些衍生品最终进入了它们不属于的地方，进入了本不该承担这种风险的地方。
this amount of risk. Things like pension funds that should be relatively safe investments. Why did they end up there? Because the people buying them just did not appreciate or realize how complicated they were and so what happened was when the price of What real estate in the United States? started going down these products which were tied to the value of real estate and like the default probabilities on mortgages,
比如养老金基金，这本该是相对安全的投资。它们为什么会流向那里？因为购买它们的人根本没有意识到或认识到它们有多么复杂，所以发生的事情是，当美国房地产的价格开始下跌时，这些与房地产价值以及抵押贷款违约概率挂钩的产品，
they crashed in value. And there was this huge amount of risk in our financial system because these products had entered into all these different areas and they were highly represented in all these different areas. And all of a sudden, kind of everybody was caught by surprise that the pension fund
它们的价值崩溃了。我们的金融系统中存在着巨额风险，因为这些产品已经进入了所有这些不同的领域，并且在所有这些不同的领域中占据了很大比例。突然之间，几乎每个人都被打了个措手不及，养老金基金正在损失其巨大价值，因为它接触了这些高风险的东西，因为人们没有意识到风险就在那里。
was losing a huge amount of its value because it had exposure to these very risky things, because people didn't realize that the risk was there. I mean, in some ways, it's analogous to what happened on the plane. You know, the planes are getting so complex that the pilots, in fact, are trusting the plane most of the time to fly itself.
我的意思是，在某些方面，这类似于飞机上发生的事情。你知道，飞机变得越来越复杂，以至于飞行员实际上在大多数时间都信任飞机自己飞行。
And perhaps traders or people who manage pension funds are basically looking out of the market and the market has gotten so complex that they basically are saying, okay, we trust that these big banks know what they're doing, these big hedge funds know what they're doing. And in some ways they're outsourcing or reducing their own capabilities
也许交易员或管理养老金基金的人基本上是在观望市场，而市场变得如此复杂，以至于他们基本上在说，好吧，我们相信这些大银行知道他们在做什么，这些大基金知道他们在做什么。在某些方面，他们是将应对危机的自身能力外包或减少了，部分原因是情况变得太复杂了。
to actually deal with a crisis, partly because the situation has gotten so complex. That's absolutely right. And I think it happens at more than one level. So if you think about a pension fund manager who knows what a derivative is, but isn't a super expert in a derivative, he's relying on the people who do the analysis of the derivatives to kind of think, oh, this is potentially like a good investment vehicle for my portfolio. He's not thinking in super careful detail
完全正确。而且我认为它发生在不止一个层面上。因此，如果你想到一个懂什么是衍生品但并非衍生品超级专家的养老金基金经理，他依赖于做衍生品分析的人，从而认为“这可能是一个适合我投资组合的好投资工具”。他没有进行超级仔细的思考
about what the risk profile is of that instrument. And maybe he or she should be, but they obviously didn't. But it also occurs at another level, which is the person who actually is the super expert on the derivative, even that person, it turned out, didn't understand completely how these things were going to behave. So the big banks who were developing these instruments and selling them, they would have a mathematical model that would determine exactly how these things would behave.
关于该工具的风险配置文件是什么。也许他或她应该这样做，但他们显然没有。但这还发生在另一个层面上，即真正是衍生品超级专家的人，甚至连那个人，结果也并不完全理解这些东西将如何表现。因此，开发和销售这些工具的大银行会有一个数学模型来确切决定这些东西将如何表现。
The problem is that those mathematical models work really well most of the time, like an airplane that's highly automated, but they actually break down in very unusual situations, a black swan event, so to speak. The models failed and so the super experts on derivatives even they completely misunderstood the amount of risk that was present in these products. So it was across the entire financial system that there was these sort of miscalibrations in understanding and there was this cascade effect that started with some slight decreases in the price of housing and then just cascaded into this massive crash and devastation that not only affected the United States but affected countries all over the world because the entire global system is so connected nowadays. When we come back, why we imagine we know more than we do and what we can do about it. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
问题是，这些数学模型在大多数时间运行得非常好，就像一架高度自动化的飞机一样，但它们在非常不寻常的情况下（也就是所谓的黑天鹅事件）实际上会崩溃。模型失效了，因此即使是衍生品方面的超级专家，也完全误解了这些产品中存在的风险。因此，整个金融体系都存在这种对理解的错误校准，并产生了一种连锁反应，从住房价格的小幅下跌开始，然后演变成这场巨大的崩溃和破坏，不仅影响了美国，还影响了世界各地的国家，因为如今整个全球体系是如此紧密相连。我们回来后，将探讨为什么我们想象自己知道的比实际知道的多，以及我们能对此做些什么。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. Perhaps you've had the experience of driving to an important event. You're running late and you decide you want to outsmart all the other drivers who are stuck in traffic. You take a side street because you know it's a shortcut around the traffic jam. Three blocks later, you realize the shortcut isn't a shortcut. In fact, it doesn't get you where you need to go. What do you tell yourself in moments like that?
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。也许你有过这样的经历：开车去参加一个重要活动。你快迟到了，决定要智胜所有塞在交通里的其他司机。你走了一条小路，因为你知道这是绕过交通堵塞的捷径。三条街后，你意识到这条捷径根本不是捷径。事实上，它根本带不去你需要去的地方。你在那种时刻对自己说什么？
Do you say, oh, I got that really wrong? Or do you say, my sense of navigation is impeccable, except for this one tiny misstep. Philip Funback is a cognitive scientist at the Leeds School of Business at the University of Colorado Boulder. Phil, as a cognitive scientist, you've studied how humans can be so brilliant, but also really dumb. That feels like a paradox.
你是说，“哦，我彻底搞错了”？还是说，“我的导航感无可挑剔，除了这个小小的失误”？菲利普·芬巴赫是科罗拉多大学博尔德分校利兹商学院的认知科学家。菲尔，作为一名认知科学家，你研究了人类如何能够如此聪明，却又如此愚蠢。这感觉像是一个悖论。
That is a paradox, and that is the paradox at the heart of humankind, I think. On the one hand, we've visited the moon and created incredible artificial intelligence and all these other sort of almost magical abilities. On the other hand, everybody knows that people can engage in behavior that's incredibly ignorant and extreme and foolish. And we've all done it ourselves and we've all seen it in others. So, researchers who study the mind have come up with a term to describe why our own ignorance is often hidden from us. They call it the illusion of knowledge. What is this illusion, Phil? The illusion of knowledge is the idea that we think that we understand the world in much
这是一个悖论，我认为这也是人类心灵核心的悖论。一方面，我们访问了月球，创造了不可思议的人工智能以及所有其他几乎可以说是神奇的能力。另一方面，每个人都知道人们会表现出令人难以置信的无知、极端和愚蠢的行为。我们自己都做过，也都在别人身上看到过。因此，研究人类思维的研究人员想出了一个词来描述为什么我们的无知常常对我们隐藏起来。他们称之为知识错觉。这种错觉是什么，菲尔？
greater detail than we actually do. In cognitive science, this is sometimes called the illusion of explanatory depth. There was great research done by a psychologist at Yale named Frank Kyle and his colleagues in the 1990s. And that's precisely what they were interested in. How well do people understand how everyday objects work? Things like toilets or ballpoint pens or zippers. And in these studies what they asked people to do was to first just give a sort of impression of
知识错觉是指我们认为自己对世界的理解比实际要详细得多的想法。在认知科学中，这有时被称为解释深度错觉。耶鲁大学的一位心理学家弗兰克·凯尔和他的同事在 20 世纪 90 年代做了出色的研究。这正是他们感兴趣的。人们对日常物品的工作原理理解得有多好？比如马桶、圆珠笔或拉链。在这些研究中，他们要求人们做的第一件事是，先对
how well they understand things. And what's fun about this experiment is that your listeners can actually do this experiment on themselves right now. So think about it. How well do you understand how a toilet works? And if you're like most people, you're kind of nodding your head right now and saying, well, I have a decent understanding of how a toilet works.
自己对事物的理解程度给出一个大致的印象。这个实验有趣的地方在于，你的听众现在实际上可以在自己身上做这个实验。所以想一想。你对马桶的工作原理理解得有多好？如果你像大多数人一样，你现在可能会点头说，嗯，我对马桶的工作原理有相当不错的理解。
You think that somewhere in your mind is something like an annotated plumbing diagram that you could tell us about. But here's the trick. In the next part of the experiment, what I'm going to do is I'm going to ask you to explain to me in detail exactly how it works. And when I do that, something really remarkable happens. People reach inside and they realize they have just about nothing to say. It turns out that we tend to know remarkably little about the way that the world works.
你认为你的脑海里某处有一个类似于带注释的管道图的东西，你可以向我们讲述。但诀窍在这里。在实验的下一步中，我要做的是请你向我详细解释它是如何运作的。当我这样做时，一件非常奇妙的事情发生了。人们在脑海中搜索，却发现自己几乎无话可说。事实证明，我们对世界运作方式的了解少得惊人。
And yet, that initial impression we have is that we do understand in a lot of depth. And that's what Kyle called the illusion of explanatory depth, and is sometimes referred to more simply as an illusion of knowledge or an illusion of understanding. So when it comes to something like a toilet, I think most people imagine, you know, you press a handle and water flows into the bowl and the toilet flushes and that's how the toilet works. So that's actually most of the time pretty much all you need to know about how a toilet works until the toilet breaks and you have to fix it and then you realize actually there's a lot more
然而，我们最初的印象是我们确实有很深的理解。这就是凯尔所说的解释深度错觉，有时更简单地被称为知识错觉或理解错觉。因此，当谈到像马桶这样的东西时，我想大多数人会想象，你知道，你按一下手柄，水流入水箱，马桶冲水，这就是马桶的工作原理。所以在大多数情况下，这实际上差不多就是你需要知道的关于马桶工作原理的全部，直到马桶坏了，你不得不修理它，然后你才意识到实际上还有很多
going on. At this point, you may be asking yourself, how do toilets work? I asked Phil to test his own knowledge, but he declined to offer an explanation from memory. As he put it, he's learned it about 10 million times, but can never retain it. So here he is reading the explanation. So the most popular flush toilet in North America
正在发生的事情。此时，你可能会问自己：马桶是如何工作的？我请菲尔测试他自己的知识，但他拒绝凭记忆做出解释。正如他所说，他已经学过大约一千万次，但从来记不住。所以这里他在阅读解释。因此，北美最受欢迎的抽水马桶
is the siphoning toilet. And by the way, this is a really ingenious mechanism that was created. Its most important components are a tank, a bowl, and a trapway. The trapway is usually S or U-shaped, and it curves up higher than the outlet of the bowl before descending into the drainpipe
是虹吸式马桶。顺便说一句，这是一个非常巧妙的机制。它最重要的组件是水箱、水斗和存水弯。存水弯通常呈 S 形或 U 形，它向上弯曲得比水斗的出水口还要高，然后向下延伸到最终通往排污管的
that eventually feeds the sewer. The tank is initially full of water and when the toilet is flushed the water flows from the tank quickly into the bowl raising the water level above the highest curve of the trapway. This purges the trapway of air filling it with water. As soon as the trapway fills the magic occurs. A siphon effect is created that sucks the water out of the bowl and sends it through the trapway down the drain. It's the same siphon action that you can use to steal gasoline out of a car by placing one end in the tank and sucking on the other end.
排水管中。水箱最初装满了水，当马桶冲水时，水从水箱迅速流入水斗，使水位上升到存水弯最高曲线以上。这清除了存水弯中的空气，将其注满水。一旦存水弯注满水，奇迹就发生了。产生了一种虹吸效应，将水从水斗中吸出，并通过存水弯送入排水管。这就是你可以用来从汽车里偷汽油的同一种虹吸作用，只要把一端放进油箱，吸另一端就可以了。
Let me try and say it back to you to see if I can test my own illusion of knowledge here. What I think it's saying is that you have this S-shaped curve in the pipe behind the toilet bowl and as you flush the toilet, it fills with water, it starts to fill up this S-shaped pipe and as it fills up the pipe with water, the water basically pushes out the air creating something of a vacuum on the back end of this S-shaped pipe and the vacuum then suctions the rest of the water inside the bowl out into the drain. How did I do, Phil? Well, I think we should test that with a plumber, not with me, but I think you did a pretty good job.
让我试着复述给你听，看看我是否能在这里测试我自己的知识错觉。我的理解是，马桶水斗后面管道中有一个 S 形弯曲，当你冲马桶时，它充满了水，开始填满这个 S 形管道，当它把水填满管道时，水基本上把空气挤了出去，在这个 S 形管道的后端产生了一定的真空，然后这个真空将水斗内的其余水吸入排水管。我做得怎么样，菲尔？嗯，我认为我们应该找一个水管工来测试，而不是找我，但我认为你做得挺不错的。
What you're saying is I should stick to podcasting and not plumbing is the advice I'm hearing you give me. I think we both should. But what this highlights is just how complicated the world is. Whoever thought, you know, there's this ingenious mechanism in this object that we use every single day and we never think about. So talk a moment about how the illusion of knowledge in some ways is a product of the way the human mind works and its limitations as it interacts with this extremely complex world. Why is it that the workings of the world are so hard for us to wrap our heads around, Phil? I think this reflects a really deep fact about the nature of the mind are so hard for us to wrap our heads around, Phil. I think this reflects a really deep fact
你的意思是，我应该坚持做播客，而不是当水管工，这是我听到的你的建议。我想我们两个都应该。但这凸显了世界的复杂性。谁能想到，你知道，在我们每天都在使用却从不思考的这个物体中，竟然存在着如此巧妙的机制。那么，请花点时间谈谈，为什么知识错觉在某些方面是人类思维工作方式及其在与这个极其复杂的世界互动时的局限性的产物？为什么世界的运作对我们来说如此难以理解，菲尔？我认为这反映了关于思维本质的一个非常深刻的事实，
about the nature of the mind and what thinking is actually for. Thinking evolved to make us more effective at acting in the world. The world is extremely complex. And to be able to choose effective actions in the world really requires acting in environments that are very different from one another. We almost never see the same exact situation arise twice.
即思考到底是为了什么。思维的进化是为了使我们在世界上采取行动时更有效率。世界极其复杂。要在世界上选择有效的行动，确实需要在彼此非常不同的环境中采取行动。我们几乎从未见过完全相同的清况出现两次。
And so our minds have to be really effective at generalization. They have to understand that this situation is similar to this situation in some way to be able to act effectively. So storing a huge amount of detail about the world and the way that it works is actually counterproductive. What we really wanna do is throw away
因此，我们的思维必须非常擅长概括。它们必须理解这种情况在某种程度上类似于那种情况，以便能够有效地行动。因此，存储关于世界及其运作方式的大量细节实际上是适得其反的。我们真正想要做的是扔掉
all of the irrelevant detail and just retain the deeper principles, the deeper generalizable structures that are going to allow us to choose effective actions. And of course this must be true for all manner of different things in the world. Everything from you know bacteria to how trees work to how a hurricane works. All of these in some ways are complex phenomena where we have a general understanding of what bacteria do, a general understanding of what a
所有不相关的细节，只保留更深层的原则、更深层的可推广结构，这些将使我们能够选择有效的行动。当然，这对于世界上各种不同的事物来说一定都是真的。从你知道的细菌到树木的工作方式，再到飓风的工作方式。在某种程度上，所有这些都是复杂的现象，我们对细菌的作用有一般的了解，对飓风是什么有一般的了解，但没有对颗粒水平上实际发生的精确力学的了解。
hurricane is, but not the exact mechanics of what's actually happening at a granular level That's exactly right. The world is so complex when you start When you start digging into the details of almost anything You realize how complicated it is and that you don't necessarily appreciate that complexity off to that I remember hearing a story about a rock paper scissors tournament. Do you know the game Rock Paper Scissors? Yes, yeah. Very simple game, right?
完全正确。当你开始深入研究几乎任何东西的细节时，你会发现世界是多么复杂，你并不一定能欣赏到这种复杂性。我记得听过一个关于石头剪刀布锦标赛的故事。你知道石头剪刀布这个游戏吗？是的，是的。非常简单的游戏，对吧？
It seems like there's nothing to learn and nothing to understand about that game. How could you have a tournament? You just throw randomly. Well, actually it turns out that there's a group of people who have gotten really good at rock paper scissors. And what do they do? They master the details of how the human mind chooses
似乎关于那个游戏没有什么可学的，也没有什么可理解的。怎么能举办锦标赛呢？你随便出就行了。嗯，实际上事实证明，有一群人已经非常擅长石头剪刀布了。他们做什么呢？他们掌握了人类思维如何选择
what to throw and how it engages in pattern matching and other kinds of things. And they can identify certain kinds of patterns in what a more novice rock, paper, scissors player will do and take advantage of that. I see. So in other words, if I'm a novice there might be certain patterns that I slip into unconsciously without realizing I've slipped into the pattern and if you're an expert you sort of can take advantage of that. That's exactly right. It's a funny kind of dumb example but
出什么以及如何进行模式匹配和其他类型的事情的细节。他们可以识别出较不熟练的石头剪刀布玩家所做的某些类型的模式，并利用这一点。我明白了。换句话说，如果我是个新手，我可能会陷入某些无意识的模式中，而没有意识到自己已经陷入了这种模式，如果你是专家，你就可以利用这一点。完全正确。这是一个有趣的、愚蠢的例子，但
something where when I first looked at it I said there is no way that somebody could develop any level of expertise in that area. But it turns out, no, there is actually something to be learned there. So we can see the problem with mastering too much detail about the world. When we look at people with a very rare condition called hyperthymesia, what is this condition, Phil?
当我第一次看到它时，我说，绝对不可能有人在那个领域发展出任何水平的专家水平。但事实证明，不，实际上确实有些东西是可以学习的。因此，我们可以看到掌握世界过多细节的问题。当我们看到患有一种叫做超忆症的非常罕见的疾病的人时，这种疾病是什么，菲尔？
How does it work? Yeah, this is a super fascinating example. So hyperthymesia is also called highly superior autobiographical memory. And these are people who literally remember everything that's ever happened to them. And so you could talk to a person with hyperthymesia and say, what happened to you at 10.30 on the morning on August 15th, 1985? And they can relate to exactly what occurred. They basically have perfect recall.
它是如何运作的？是的，这是一个超级迷人的例子。因此，超忆症也被称为高度优越的自传体记忆。这些人字面意思上能记住发生在他们身上的每一件事。所以你可以和一个患有超忆症的人交谈，然后问：“1985 年 8 月 15 日上午 10 点半，你发生了什么事？”他们可以准确地讲述发生了什么。他们基本上拥有完美的记忆力。
So before I described how our minds are very good at throwing away irrelevant detail. If you have hyperthymesia, it's the opposite. You retain everything that's ever happened to you. It sounds like a superpower, but it actually makes life really difficult. And there's an amazing short story by the Argentinian writer Borges, which is called Funes the Memorious. And it describes exactly this, a man who falls off a horse and develops perfect autobiographical memory so that he remembers every little detail of his life
所以我之前描述了我们的思维如何擅长抛弃不相关的细节。如果你有超忆症，情况恰好相反。你保留了发生在你身上的每一件事。这听起来像是一个超能力，但实际上让生活变得非常困难。阿根廷作家博尔赫斯有一篇精彩的短篇小说，名叫《博闻强记的富内斯》。它准确地描述了这一点，一个从马上摔下来并发展出完美自传体记忆的男人，他记得自己生活中的每一个小细节，这把他逼疯了。
and it drives him crazy. And that's because the purpose of thinking, the purpose of cognition is really not to store detail, it's to throw the detail away to be able to generalize. And that's such an important function of cognition. If you have this hyperthymesia, it actually makes life really difficult. So what I hear you saying, Phil,
这是因为思考的目的、认知的目的其实不是为了存储细节，而是为了抛弃细节以便能够进行概括。这是认知的一个非常重要的功能。如果你有这种超忆症，它实际上会让生活变得非常困难。所以听你这么说，菲尔，
is that in many ways it's actually more efficient and more effective for us to discard a lot of details or maybe even never learn the details in the first place and stick with this very generalized you know understanding of the world. So the problem is not that we don't know everything that's just the human condition the problem is that most of us think we know more than we actually do. In fact it would be futile to try to know everything. The world is just way too complex. We've already talked about that. There's just no way that an individual can know enough about the world that it would be effective to
在许多方面，丢弃很多细节，甚至一开始就永远不要了解细节，而坚持这种非常笼统的对世界的理解，对我们来说实际上更有效率、更有效。所以问题不在于我们不知道一切，那只是人类的状况，问题在于我们大多数人都认为自己知道的比实际知道的多。事实上，试图了解一切将是徒劳的。世界实在太复杂了。我们已经讨论过这一点。个人根本不可能了解足够多的世界，以至于将关于一切的所有细节都存储起来会是有效的。这只是身为人类的组成部分。我们没有意识到自己不理解的程度，这确实是一个问题。
store all the details about everything. That's just part and parcel of what it means to be a human being. It is a problem that we don't appreciate the extent to which we don't understand. So in April 1995, a man named MacArthur Wheeler came up with what seemed to him to be a foolproof way to rob banks and get away with it. Tell me what he did, Phil. This is a crazy story. So this guy was under the impression that he would be invisible to the cameras if he put lemon juice on his face. You remember when you were a kid, you
所以在 1995 年 4 月，一个名叫麦克阿瑟·惠勒的男人想出了一个在他看来是抢劫银行并全身而退的万无一失的方法。告诉我他做了什么，菲尔。这是一个疯狂的故事。所以这家伙有个印象，如果他把柠檬汁抹在脸上的话，摄像头就会看不见他。你还记得你小时候，
could create invisible ink by putting lemon juice on the paper. So he thought for some reason that this would apply to making him invisible to the camera. So he actually went in to try to rob a bank with no mask, no subterfuge whatsoever, just lemon juice on his face. So his image is broadcast on the news. Within minutes, the police arrive at his door to arrest him and he is completely incredulous. How could they have possibly known it was him
你可以通过把柠檬汁抹在纸上来制造隐形墨水吗？所以他出于某种原因认为这同样适用于让他对摄像头隐形。所以他实际上在没有戴面具、没有任何伪装的情况下试图抢劫银行，脸上只抹了柠檬汁。于是他的形象在新闻上播出了。几分钟内，警察就来到他家门口逮捕了他，而他完全难以置信。他们怎么可能知道那是他，
because he had the lemon juice on his face? And in fact, it turned out that he had tested the method by taking a Polaroid of himself and making sure that his face was indeed invisible to the Polaroid camera. It's never been discovered why the Polaroid camera. It's never been discovered why the Polaroid didn't show his face, but one possibility is that he missed because his eyes were filled with lemon juice.
因为他脸上抹了柠檬汁？事实上，事实证明，他通过给自己拍了一张宝丽来照片来测试这种方法，以确保他的脸确实对宝丽来相机隐形。人们从未发现为什么宝丽来相机没有拍出他的脸，但有一种可能性是，他失手了，因为他的眼睛里塞满了柠檬汁。
So what you're saying is he was not just a terrible bank robber, he was a terrible photographer as well. Apparently so. Phil has also found that our faulty memories play a role in the illusion of knowledge. Take for instance the research into how good people think they are when it comes to making smart investments in the stock market. when it comes to making smart investments in the stock market. It's been well documented that people tend to be very overconfident in their capabilities in terms of beating the market and that can lead to really disastrous outcomes like people take on too much risk and it actually turns out that the more people actively trade the worse they do and active trading is sort of an indicator of being overconfident in your ability to beat the market.
所以你的意思是，他不仅是一个糟糕的银行劫匪，还是一个糟糕的摄影师。显然是的。菲尔还发现，我们有缺陷的记忆在知识错觉中起着作用。以关于人们在对股市进行明智投资时认为自己有多优秀的研究为例。
This is a paper that I wrote with Dan Walters. And what we found in this paper is that one reason for the overconfidence, the reason that people feel that they can beat the market is because they tend to remember the good outcomes and forget the bad outcomes. So if I make a trade and I do great on it, that one's gonna stick in my memory,
人们在击败市场的这方面的能力往往过于自信，这一点已被充分记录，这可能导致真正灾难性的结果，比如人们承担了太多的风险，而事实证明，人们越积极地交易，他们做得越差，积极交易可以说是对你击败市场能力过于自信的一个指标。这是我和丹·沃尔特斯合写的一篇论文。我们在论文中发现，过度自信的一个原因，人们觉得他们可以击败市场的原因是，他们倾向于记住好的结果而忘记坏的结果。所以如果我做了一笔交易，我在这上面做得很好，那笔交易就会留在我的记忆中，
more so than when I make a trade and it does poorly. That's not to say that if you have a really disastrous trade that you're not gonna remember that, you certainly would. But on average, you're gonna tend to inflate the good over the bad. And one average, you're going to tend to inflate the good over the bad. And one reason for that is because we tend to remember the things that help us maintain a positive self-image. We want to believe that we're smart and good at investing. That's a very natural human tendency to want to remember the good and kind of forget the bad. And so this doesn't just
比我做了一笔交易却表现不佳时更甚。这并不是说如果你有一笔非常糟糕的交易，你就不会记得了，你当然会。但平均而言，你往往会夸大好的地方，而忽视不好的地方。而平均而言，你往往会夸大好的地方，而忽视不好的地方。其中一个原因是因为我们倾向于记住那些有助于我们维持积极自我形象的事情。我们希望相信自己很聪明，擅长投资。想要记住好的方面而多少忘记坏的方面，这是非常自然的人类倾向。所以这不仅
occur in the domain of investing, but can occur in other domains as well. So we've looked at how the illusion of knowledge and the illusion of explanatory depth applies to physical objects, things like bicycles or toilets. Can they also apply to historical events or public policy in that we imagine that we understand things better than we actually do, Phil? Yes, and that is what made me so passionate about these ideas, because it turns out that the reason that we should care about this illusion is not
发生在投资领域，也可以发生在其他领域。因此，我们已经研究了知识错觉和解释深度错觉是如何适用于物理对象的，比如自行车或马桶。它们是否也适用于历史事件或公共政策，即我们想象自己比实际更懂这些事情呢，菲尔？是的，这就是让我对这些想法如此充满热情的原因，因为事实证明，我们应该关注这种错觉的原因，不是
because people don't understand how a ballpoint pen or a toilet works. But I realized at some point that the illusion applies to just about everything that we grapple with as a society and as individuals. I was doing this work in the midst of a political environment in the United States that was becoming more and more polarized.
因为人们不了解圆珠笔或马桶是如何工作的。但我在某个时刻意识到，这种错觉几乎适用于作为社会和个体的我们所 grappling（努力应对）的一切。我在美国政治环境日益两极化的背景下做这项工作。
And as I was doing this work, I had this big insight that wow, we are arguing with incredible vitriol across the aisle about issues that are extremely complex and that nobody understands in a lot of depth and detail. And yet we have these passionate, strong views and are unable to compromise across the political divide. And that was a core issue that really got me interested in this stuff. Now, I think if you talk to a lot of people
在我做这项工作的过程中，我有了这样一个深刻的见解：哇，我们在跨越党派分歧时，带着令人难以置信的尖刻，在争论那些极其复杂、且没有人有很深理解和细节的问题。然而，我们却有强烈而充满激情的观点，无法跨越政治分歧进行妥协。这是一个核心问题，真正让我对这些东西产生了兴趣。现在，我认为如果你和许多人交谈
with strong political opinions, they will say, well, you know, I do understand the issues. I do understand what it means to have, you know, universal healthcare. I do understand the consequences of a flat tax. Are they wrong? I think in many cases they are wrong. And actually we've demonstrated that in experiments.
带有强烈的政治观点的人，他们会说，嗯，你知道的，我确实理解这些问题。我确实理解拥有全民医疗保健意味着什么。我确实理解单一税（flat tax）的后果。他们错了吗？我认为在很多情况下他们是错的。事实上，我们在实验中已经证明了这一点。
So what we've done is something very akin to the toilet experiment that I described earlier. We bring people into the lab and we ask them about their position on the issues of the day, the things that we're arguing about as a society. And then we ask them how well they understand those issues. People tend to say, oh yeah, I understand it pretty well. And then we ask them to explain the mechanism,
所以我们所做的，非常类似于我之前描述的马桶实验。我们把人们带到实验室，询问他们对当前热点问题的立场，也就是我们作为社会在争论的事情。然后我们问他们对这些问题的理解程度。人们往往会说，哦，是的，我理解得相当好。然后我们让他们解释其机制，
explain in detail how it works. And we find this large decrease in the sense of understanding. So people are humbled by that because they try to explain and they realize, wow, I just have a talking point or two. I actually don't understand this thing in detail. You've also found that people who have some of the strongest views on an issue
详细解释它是如何运作的。我们发现理解感大幅下降。所以人们对此感到谦卑，因为他们试图解释却意识到，哇，我只有一个或两个谈话要点。我实际上并不详细了解这东西。你们还发现，对某个问题持有最强烈观点的人
are sometimes also those with the lowest levels of knowledge about the issue. Why would this be the case, Phil? So I've studied this in the context of controversial scientific issues. So things like the safety of genetically modified foods or the reality of climate change. In those cases, there's a substantial minority
有时也是对该问题了解水平最低的人。为什么会这样呢，菲尔？所以我一直在有争议的科学问题背景下研究这一点。比如转基因食品的安全性或气候变化的现实。在这些情况下，存在相当大的一部分少数群体
of the population who expresses really extreme, strong counter-consensus views, views that are counter to the scientific consensus. And what we find in that case is that the people who have the strongest counter-consensus views have the highest levels of subjective understanding. They feel like they understand these issues the best, which makes sense because if I feel like I understand it
他们表达了非常极端、强烈的反共识观点，即违背科学共识的观点。我们在这种情况下发现的是，那些持有最强烈反共识观点的人，具有最高水平的主观理解。他们觉得自己对这些问题的理解最好，这合情合理，因为如果我觉得自己理解得
really well, I'm gonna have a strong opinion. But when we measure their actual understanding of the issue in a variety of ways, they actually have the lowest levels of objective knowledge. So when you put those things together, the people who have the most extreme counter consensus views have this huge gap between what they think they know and what they actually know.
非常好，我就会有强烈的意见。但当我们通过各种方式衡量他们对该问题的实际理解时，他们的客观知识水平实际上最低。所以当你把这些结合起来，那些拥有最极端反共识观点的人，在他们自以为知道的与他们实际知道的之间，存在着巨大的鸿沟。
Why do you think that's happening? The fact itself, of course, is striking and surprising, but is there a relationship between the two? Is the fact that they don't know partly what causes their certainty? I think that that's right. So if I feel like I understand something and I feel like I know it well,
你认为为什么会这样？这个事实本身当然是惊人且出人意料的，但这两者之间存在某种联系吗？他们不了解情况，是否部分导致了他们的确定性？我认为是这样的。所以如果我觉得自己懂某件事，并且我觉得自己很了解它，
I'm gonna be less likely to listen to counter-evidence and counter-explanations, or to do more research into the issue to learn more about it. If I already feel like I understand it, it's really hard to reach me with counter-evidence. And so the people whose views seem to be the most out of line with what the scientific community says
我就会更少地去听反证和反向解释，或者对这个问题做更多的研究以了解更多。如果我自以为已经懂了，用反证来触及我就真的很难了。所以那些观点似乎最不符合科学界说法的那些人
are the ones who are hardest to reach because they already feel like they understand the issue. It turns out that many of the problems that beset us in the modern world have a common source. We think we know something when actually we don't. When we come back, combating the knowledge illusion. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain.
是最难被触及的，因为他们已经觉得自己理解这个问题了。事实证明，现代社会困扰我们的许多问题都有一个共同的根源。我们自以为知道某事，而实际上并不了解。稍后回来，对抗知识错觉。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. Philip Fernbach is a cognitive scientist at the Leeds School of Business at the University of Colorado Boulder. Phil, you say that in the face of the knowledge illusion, one effective way to better align what we think we know with what we actually know is to challenge ourselves to explain technologies, procedures, and policies in our own words.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。菲利普·费恩巴赫是科罗拉多大学博尔德分校利兹商学院的认知科学家。菲尔，你说过，面对知识错觉，将我们的认知与实际所知更好地对齐的一个有效方法，就是挑战自己用自己的话来解释技术、程序和政策。
Why does this dispel the knowledge illusion? So we're not in the habit of engaging in a lot of explanation most of the time. We just take things for granted as we've been discussing. And so when we get in the habit of doing that, it's sort of hard to hide from ourselves that we don't understand things as well as we thought we did. A great example of this comes from work by Rebecca Lawson on people's understanding of bicycles. So if you ask somebody, do you know how a bicycle works? A lot of people say, oh yeah, I kind of know how that works.
为什么这能消除知识错觉？所以我们大多数时候并没有经常进行解释的习惯。正如我们一直在讨论的那样，我们只是把事情视为理所当然。因此，当我们养成这样做的习惯时，很难向自己隐瞒我们其实并不像自己想象的那样了解事物。这方面的一个极好的例子来自丽贝卡·劳森（Rebecca Lawson）关于人们对自行车理解的研究。因此，如果你问某人，你知道自行车是如何工作的吗？很多人会说，哦，是的，我大概知道它是怎么工作的。
But then in the study, what she did was she asked people to draw a bicycle. And if you sit down and try to do it, I encourage the listeners to try to do it. It's much more difficult than you might have anticipated and that's just a great example of in that case it's impossible to hide from yourself the gaps in your knowledge. They've just become revealed on the page as you try to draw.
但在研究中，她所做的是要求人们画一辆自行车。如果你坐下来试着画，我鼓励听众们也试着画一下。这比你预期的要困难得多，这正是一个极好的例子：在这种情况下，你不可能向自己隐瞒知识中的漏洞。当你试图画出来时，它们就在纸上暴露无遗了。
I mean in some ways this is not hugely different from what happens in a school setting where you're giving a student a test and you're basically saying, produce for me your knowledge. You think that you know how differential equations work. Produce for me that knowledge by solving this problem. That's right. A test that is designed to actually gauge understanding of the way things work, as opposed to a test that is merely regurgitating facts. So a test that's well designed to actually evaluate whether somebody understands the details or mechanisms of the way that something works
我的意思是，在某些方面，这与学校里的情况并没有太大区别，在那里你给学生一场考试，基本上是在说：向我展示你的知识。你以为你知道微分方程是如何运作的。通过解出这道题向我展示这些知识。没错。旨在真正评估对事物运作方式理解的考试，而不是仅仅死记硬背事实的考试。因此，一场设计得很好、能够真正评估某人是否理解事物运作细节或机制的考试
would indeed reveal those gaps. I have a colleague who was recently telling me a story about one of his classes where he was just imploring students, if you are using artificial intelligence to try to help you with the class, make sure that you understand this and not just are using the artificial intelligence. And yet when the test came around and they'd all been using ChachiBT, they learned that
确实会暴露出这些漏洞。我有一位同事最近在给我讲一个关于他某堂课的故事，他在课上恳求学生们，如果你正在使用人工智能来帮助你上这门课，请确保你理解了这些内容，而不仅仅是在使用人工智能。然而，当考试来临，他们都在使用 ChatGPT 时，他们了解到
they did not understand the material as well as they thought that they did because they had been relying on the artificial intelligence. And they got very upset with him and he sort of explained to them, look, I tried to tell you but this is such a natural human thing to overestimate our understanding that it's very hard to actually appreciate the gaps in our knowledge. We often, it's so natural for us to go through life just not really questioning and assuming we know more than we do, that we don't really see it.
他们对材料的理解并没有他们想象的那么好，因为他们一直依赖人工智能。他们对他的表现感到非常沮丧，他向他们解释说，看，我试图告诉你，但高估我们的理解力是如此自然的人类本性，以至于很难真正意识到我们知识中的漏洞。我们常常习惯于在生活中不加质疑，假设自己比实际知道的要多，以至于我们并没有真正看到这一点。
And that's why getting into this habit of questioning yourself and questioning your understanding is a very powerful tool for dispelling the illusion. So you've asked people with strong views on political issues to explain public policies in detail. What effect does this have on their certainties, Phil? So in our studies, we've often compared two different types of explanations. One is this mechanistic explanation, how does it work? And the other is more about why you believe what you do, so reasons.
这就是为什么养成质疑自己、质疑自己理解的习惯是消除这种错觉的强大工具。所以你曾要求对政治问题有强烈的看法的人详细解释公共政策。这会对他们的确定性产生什么影响，菲尔？因此，在我们的研究中，我们经常比较两种不同类型的解释。一种是机械解释，它是如何运作的？另一种更多是关于你为什么相信你所相信的，也就是原因。
And you can think about those two modes of thinking as being more explanatory or mechanistic on the one hand, and then more argumentatory or mechanistic on the one hand and then more argumentative or Advocacy based on the other hand. I think we are much more commonly engaged in this argumentation or advocacy When we're talking about things like political issues, we very rarely engage in this kind of mechanistic or explanatory kind of discussion in this kind of mechanistic or explanatory kind of discussion.
你可以把这两种思维模式看作一方面更具解释性或机械性，另一方面更具论辩性或机械性，以及另一方面更具论辩性或倡导性。我认为当我们在谈论政治问题之类的事情时，我们更常见地参与这种论辩或倡导，我们很少参与这种机械性或解释性的讨论，在这种机械性或解释性的讨论中。
But it turns out that the mechanistic or explanatory mode leads to a little more open-mindedness. It gets people to be a little less certain about their positions because it reveals the complexity of issues. And this has been demonstrated to some extent in our work where we simply ask people, how do you feel about these issues afterwards? But I think even more interestingly and meaningfully, there was a great paper by El-Nakori Hun and Grossman a few years ago, and they asked people on different sides of the political divide to have political discussions.
但事实证明，机械或解释性模式能带来更多一点的开放思维。它让人们对自己的立场没那么确定，因为它揭示了问题的复杂性。这一点在我们的工作在某种程度上得到了证明，我们只是简单地询问人们事后对这些问题的感受。但我认为更有趣、更有意义的是，几年前埃尔-纳科里·洪和格罗斯曼写过一篇出色的论文，他们要求政治分歧不同边的人进行政治讨论。
And then they measured different things about the discussion, like how well it went and how open-minded people seemed to be and how much they were listening to the other side and those kinds of things. I mean, what they found is that the discussions were more productive when people engaged in this more explanatory kind of discussion. Did you find that when people are asked to engage in this more explanatory style of conversation, that political polarization
然后他们衡量了关于讨论的不同方面，比如进展得如何、人们显得多么开放、他们倾听对方的程度以及诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，他们发现当人们参与这种更具解释性的讨论时，讨论会更富有成效。你是否发现，当人们被要求参与这种更具解释性的对话风格时，政治两极分化
goes down because some of people's political certainties go down? It does. They move to the middle a little bit. The challenge with that is that people get defensive as well. So if you challenge people with their understanding, they might actually double down and say, no, I know what I'm talking about. Because people naturally tend to be a little bit defensive. So the way to actually implement such an intervention can be a little bit challenging in its details.
会下降，因为人们的一些政治确定性下降了？确实如此。他们稍微向中间靠拢了。其中的挑战在于人们也会产生防御心理。因此，如果你用他们的理解去挑战他们，他们实际上可能会加倍坚持，并说：不，我知道我在说什么。因为人们天生倾向于有一点防御心理。所以实际实施这样的干预措施在细节上可能会有些挑战。
Because again, human beings are not simple, they're complex. So if you reveal people's lack of understanding to them, it may have the effect of making them a little bit more humble or more moderate, but it could also make them double down on their the effect of making them a little bit more humble or more moderate, but it could also make them double down on their position a little bit. I'm wondering whether you might have advice for people who are sitting across a table with a friend or family member with whom they're having a really strenuous disagreement or debate.
因为再次强调，人类并不简单，他们是复杂的。因此，如果你向人们揭示他们缺乏理解，可能会起到让他们变得更谦虚或更温和一点的效果，但这也可能让他们更 加倍地坚持自己的立场，效果可能会让他们对自己的立场更加坚定一点。我在想，你是否能给那些坐在桌子对面、与有激烈分歧或辩论的朋友或家人交谈的人一些建议？
How would you encourage them to invite the other person to engage in explanatory thinking as opposed to argumentative thinking? The key is to be curious about the other side's position. So if you start from a perspective of the other side is not as smart as me, is not as ethical or moral as me, they're bad, they're stupid, then you're not gonna be likely to have a very productive discussion. If you start instead with the perspective of
你会如何鼓励他们引导对方参与解释性思维，而不是争论性思维？关键是要对对方的立场保持好奇。因此，如果你从“对方不如我聪明、不如我道德、他们是坏的、是愚蠢的”这种视角出发，那么你就不太可能进行一次富有成效的讨论。相反，如果你从以下视角出发：
the person that I'm talking to is as smart as me and as moral as me, then you become curious. Why is it that they maintain a strong position that's so different from yours when it seems like the right answer is just so obvious to you and then when you become curious and if both sides are mutually curious and they want to understand what is behind the other side's position then you can have a more productive
我交谈的人和我一样聪明，和我一样有道德，那么你就会产生好奇心。为什么当正确的答案对你来说如此显而易见时，他们却坚持一个与你如此不同的坚定立场呢？然后，当你产生好奇心，如果双方都抱有相互的好奇心，并且他们想要理解对方立场背后的东西时，你们就能进行更有成效的
discussion and I think what you will find is that when you engage jointly in this explanatory kind of discussion it's more of a collaboration than it is an argument. And that collaboration is gonna reveal, likely, that both sides don't know as much as they thought they did at the beginning. That's gonna be the most common outcome. I mean, I think one thing that I take away from that is that even when we encounter people with beliefs that are very different from our own or even
讨论。我认为你会发现，当你共同参与这种解释性的讨论时，与其说是一场争论，不如说是一次合作。这种合作很可能会揭示出，双方其实都并不像他们一开始以为的那样了解那么多。这将是最常见的结果。我的意思是，我认为我从中吸取的一点是，即使我们遇到信仰与我们截然不同的人，甚至
beliefs that we can prove are certifiably wrong, perhaps the right response actually is is some degree of compassion because in some ways I think what I hear you saying is that the process by which they are arriving at their erroneous beliefs is not different than the process at which I arrive at what might be correct beliefs. I agree with that 100% because we all have beliefs that are incorrect and we all have beliefs that we have much more strength and conviction in
我们可以证明其信仰绝对错误的人，也许正确的反应实际上是某种程度的同理心，因为在某种程度上，我认为我听到你所说的是，他们得出错误信仰的过程，与我得出可能是正确信仰的过程并没有什么不同。我百分之百同意这一点，因为我们都有不正确的信念，我们所有人都有比我们应有的
than we should. And conspiracies are a bizarre sort of extreme example of this, but they're part and parcel of the same kind of mechanisms that lead to all of our beliefs. So another way to better grasp what we don't know So, another way to better grasp what we don't know is to engage in a practice of considering the unknowns. What is this practice, Phil?
更强烈的信念和确信度的信念。而阴谋论是这种现象的一种离奇的极端例子，但它们与导致我们所有信念的同一种机制密不可分。因此，更好地掌握我们所未知之事的另一种方法是，更好地掌握我们所未知之事的另一种方法是，养成考虑未知事物的习惯。这是一种什么样的习惯，菲尔？
Yes. So, there's been a lot of research in the psychology literature on overconfidence. People tend to be overconfident in a lot of different ways. The reason for overconfidence is what's called confirmation bias. That is we're preferentially disposed to find evidence for the position that we start with, the one that we want. Some of the work that I've done
是的。因此，心理学文献中有很多关于过度自信的研究。人们往往在许多不同的方面过于自信。过度自信的原因被称为确认偏误。也就是说，我们倾向于偏爱寻找证据来支持我们最初的、我们想要的立场。我所做的一些工作
is looking at another reason that we're overconfident. It's not just because we tend to preferentially weight the evidence for our positions, but also that we tend to neglect all of the unknown information. And that's part and parcel of all of the themes that we've been talking about today,
是在寻找我们过度自信的另一个原因。这不仅是因为我们倾向于优先权衡支持我们立场的证据，还因为我们往往忽略了所有未知的信息。这与我们今天一直在讨论的所有主题密不可分，
that the world just seems simpler than it is. If the world seems simpler, and we're confronted with an issue, then we're gonna tend not to think about all of the stuff that we don't know. We're gonna tend to think about the stuff that we do know. And if we thought about all the stuff that we don't know, it would make us more moderate in our positions
即世界看起来比实际更简单。如果世界看起来更简单，而我们又面临一个问题，那么我们往往就不会去思考所有我们不知道的事情。我们往往会去思考我们确实知道的事情。如果我们去思考所有我们不知道的事情，这会使我们在自己的立场上更加温和，
because, wow, there's a lot more to know about this. There is another dimension of the illusion of knowledge that affects organizations and groups and it affects us when we are part of large groups. This aspect of the illusion of knowledge shapes gyrations in the stock market and your retirement portfolio. What we find is that when people search the internet for financial information, they become overconfident in their knowledge. And not only they become overconfident in their knowledge, but that leads to downstream behaviors like taking on more risk.
因为，哇，关于这个还有更多需要了解的知识。知识错觉还有另一个维度，它影响着组织和群体，并且在我们成为大群体的一部分时影响着我们。知识错觉的这一方面塑造了股市和你的退休投资组合的震荡。我们发现，当人们在互联网上搜索金融信息时，他们会对自己的知识变得过度自信。不仅他们对自己的知识变得过度自信，这还会导致下游的行为，比如承担更多的风险。
To listen, please check out the episode titled Smarter Together, Dumber Together in our subscription feed Hidden Brain Plus. If you're not yet subscribed, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Your support helps us produce high quality shows with scientific experts. Every episode of our show is thoroughly researched, fact-checked, and edited. By signing up for Hidden Brain Plus, you are helping us build a show you love. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co slash hiddenbrain.
如需收听，请查看我们订阅源 Hidden Brain Plus 中名为《携手更聪明，携手更愚蠢》（Smarter Together, Dumber Together）的一集。如果您尚未订阅，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果您使用的是 Apple 设备，请访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。您的支持帮助我们制作了以科学专家为主角的高质量节目。我们节目的每一集都经过深入研究、事实核查和剪辑。通过注册 Hidden Brain Plus，您正在帮助我们打造您喜爱的节目。再次说明，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain。
Philip Fernbach is a cognitive scientist at the Leeds School of Business at the University of Colorado Boulder. With Stephen Sloman, he is co-author of the Knowledge Illusion, Why We Never Think Alone. Phil, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. This has been a really fun conversation, Shankar. Thank you so much. today on Hidden Brain. This has been a really fun conversation Shankar, thank you so much.
菲利普·费恩巴赫是科罗拉多大学博尔德分校利兹商学院的认知科学家。他与斯蒂芬·斯洛曼（Stephen Sloman）合著了《知识错觉：为什么我们从不独自思考》（The Knowledge Illusion: Why We Never Think Alone）。菲尔，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏大脑》。这是一次非常有趣的对话，尚卡尔。非常感谢。今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。这是一次非常有趣的对话，尚卡尔，非常感谢。
Do you have follow up questions for Phil Fernbach? If you'd be willing to share your questions with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line knowledge. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsquero segment is brought to you by Discover. Our story comes from Kara Beth Rogers.
你对菲利普·费恩巴赫还有后续问题吗？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再重复一遍邮箱地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：知识。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·黄（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirrell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。今天节目最后，我们带来一个来自我们的姊妹播客《我无名英雄》（My Unsung Hero）的故事。本期《我无名英雄》片段由 Discover 赞助播出。我们的故事来自卡拉·贝思·罗杰斯（Kara Beth Rogers）。
In 2008, Kara Beth's brother Luke passed away unexpectedly. Kara Beth was 20 years old at the time, studying abroad in Morocco. The shock of the news made it nearly impossible for her to form a sentence, let alone fly all the way back to the U.S. She managed to get to the airport, but as soon as she boarded the plane, the grief became unbearable. I was sitting on an aisle and I will never forget the way that it felt to try to sit still. It was impossible. I couldn't stop moving. The like strength of the emotions was so intense. I really stood out and I felt like people were avoiding
2008年，卡拉·贝思的哥哥卢克意外去世。当时卡拉·贝思20岁，正在摩洛哥留学。这个震惊的消息让她几乎无法组织一句话，更不用说一路飞回美国了。她设法赶到了机场，但一登上飞机，悲伤就变得令人难以承受。我坐在靠过道的位置，我永远不会忘记努力坐直时的那种感觉。这太不可能了。我无法停止移动。情绪的力量是如此强烈。我真的很显眼，我觉得人们在避开
eye contact with me. They weren't really sure what to do with me. And partway through the flight, this man came up to me. I was sitting on the aisle on the right side of the plane so he came up to me and he crouched down next to me on my left side and He was so gentle he made direct eye contact with me and he spoke softly and slowly and He was really sincere
与我的目光接触。他们真的不知道该拿我怎么办。在飞行中途，这个男人向我走来。我坐在飞机右侧的过道座位上，所以他向我走来，在我左侧蹲下来，他非常温柔，直接与我目光接触，他轻声而缓慢地说话，他真的很真诚
and He said I don't I know you don't know me and I don't know what's going on for you. But I want you to know that if you need anything, I'm here. And I said, thank you. I never ended up going to him during that flight. But knowing he saw me, you know, I felt like I was in this cavern of just like untenable emotion and that I was deeply, deeply alone. And you know, having lost a brother, we were so close in age, we grew up just one year in school apart and knowing that I was on a plane with somebody that could see me and that knew that I needed something, even if I didn't know what it was,
他说，我不知——我知道你不认识我，我也不知道你发生了什么。但我希望你知道，如果你需要任何东西，我都在。我说，谢谢你。在这趟航班期间，我最终没有去找他。但知道他看到了我，你知道的，我感觉自己身处一个充满无法承受的情绪的深谷中，而且我是如此、如此地孤独。你知道的，失去了哥哥，我们年龄相仿，我们上学只差一个年级，知道飞机上有一个人能看到我，知道我需要什么，即使我不知道那是什么，
even if they didn't know what it was, was an incredibly powerful experience. I will forever be grateful for him. It was a really powerful moment for me. Kara Beth Rogers lives in Los Angeles. This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by Discover. Discover believes everyone deserves to feel special and celebrates those who exhibit the spirit in their communities. I'm a long-standing card member myself.
即使他们不知道那是什么，也是一次极其震撼的经历。我将永远感激他。对我来说，这是一个非常震撼的时刻。卡拉·贝思·罗杰斯住在洛杉矶。《我无名英雄》的这一片段由 Discover 赞助播出。Discover 相信每个人都值得感受到特别，并赞美那些在社区中展现这种精神的人。我自己也是一名长期的信用卡会员。
Learn more at discover.com slash credit card. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
了解更多信息，请访问 discover.com/creditcard。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。你 本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。